Don why do you say that you never plan
to retire well I will retire if I get a
flat on the freeway and I have to call
the AAA and they come they retire for me
because I don't know how to do that but
I want to I want to die working I want
to die and stir uh you know
between the words action and cut
or falling over my computer keyboard or
something like that because I just love
to work so much uh I really do and I
have so many friends that are just who
are much younger than me and much longer
ago than now they've just thrown in the
towel they they're just resting on their
past Laurels all they talk about is
something they did you know 40 years ago
and I don't want people to think I'm a
has been in some ways I'm doing more now
than I did when I was in my 20s you know
and but a lot of people who do the same
type who did the same types of things
I've I've done
they just don't they don't do it anymore
they have no interest they're taking day
jobs they work in stores and things like
that and um I want to keep doing what
I'm doing I'm going to keep making
movies
and keep writing
I'm writing mostly comic books again now
which is the way I started out years ago
and from a magazine called shutter and
another magazine called um vampirus
carmilla in their horror stories and
then most of the associate editor in
those two magazines and I'm having a
ball and they're better than any of the
stories I wrote 30 years ago 40 years
ago so I've improved I'd like to thank
and um
I
I just can't imagine spending the rest
of my life watching flowers grow in the
garden or watching television shows you
know
[Music]
that's just the way I am
do you think people get tired or do you
think they give up on their own ability
well in the case in the case of the Arts
and I and I use that in a broad sense
making movies writing stories drawing
pictures acting play you know playing
music whatever
a lot of there is there is a such a
thing as age bias in these businesses
like some of these places when you're
about some of the TV stations that had
hired you as a story editor or something
or even a freelance scriptwriter figure
after you're about 30 years old you're
all burned out with no new ideas and a
lot of people don't get to work anymore
when I became my own producer my own
production company
there's nobody to hire me I I do the
hiring so I can be 100 years old as long
as I can still make a movie
and get around the set and you know even
if it's a wheelchair on a walker I'm
going to keep making and have the money
to do it I'm going to keep making movies
and keep writing stories I mean how much
energy does it take sitting behind a
keyboard going like this you just got to
come up with the ideas with the stories
and a lot of people don't I see on
Facebook
former writers former artist all they
did was put up stuff they did 40 years
ago and I don't want to be known for
that I want to be I want to be known for
what I'm doing now too you know sure I
did some stuff in the past that got a
lot of notoriety and got my name all
over the place but that's not all I ever
did and I think the things I'm doing now
are better than the things I did years
ago
how do you set goals well in my case
there's two ways one is I get an idea
for something
and then I think about it and then it
starts to bug me a little bit and you
know I gotta do this and then the next
day I sit down and I start doing it the
goal could be a story or a novel or it
could be a movie or it could be a song
but when I get the idea to my head it's
there
and sometimes it bugs me I gotta
figure out how to do it
but then I do it and I finish it see a
lot of people
will start something
but they won't they can't finish it
either they don't know how to finish it
or some people have told me it's too
depressing to finish it because then
it's over with me it's not depressing
because I think it's something time to
think of something else which is equally
or maybe more exciting
the other way
is somebody will call me up and say Don
we need a such and such
we're going to pay this much money can
you do it
that's my goal at that time so either I
come up with something on my own and it
becomes a passionate thing with me or it
becomes something like a work for hire
or or something that I never would have
thought of but I but now I got to think
about it and figure it out
or something that's really their idea
but I'm the one who
brings it to life so those are the two
ways I usually do it I don't know how
other people do it
have you ever had trouble with
discipline
discipline well I was kind of a Rowdy
teenager I had a lot of problems with
discipline with
the nuns in school and my mother and
things but you mean uh sitting down and
actually doing it uh
no I never have I've never I that I can
recall in my life in my career have what
they call it as writer's plaque it might
take an extra day to think of something
but eventually it comes and um
it's funny when I write these comic book
scripts now
I'll write them in the afternoon takes
me about
three hours to knock out a
comic I'll tell you what the process is
I come up with a title
the title will be something a famous
expression
name of a product
something that I can twist around a
little bit
I was thinking I was watching something
on the Alamo
and I remember the old expression
Remember the Alamo
well thinking in horror terms like I do
the time I said what about this member
of the Alamo
you know or um
what if the night and then I come up
with an ending what kind of an ending
can I come up with a shock ending that
ties in with that title I still don't
know where the story is going to be I
have no idea what the plot's going to be
and then and they say what if before the
final battle
they discovered
that the the texicans as they were
called
were dying off
strangely with their blood drained out
of their bodies and pale skin and two
marks on the neck and nobody in the
Alamo knows what a vampire is except
this one peon who works there who came
from Spain where they knew such a thing
as El Vampiro you know well anyway this
whole thing turned out at the end you
know and to the ending of the Battle of
the Alamo where Davy Crockett is
swinging their rifle and all that but a
guy finds the skull of the vampire with
the fangs on it that they just destroyed
by driving Davey driving Jim Bowie's
Bowie knife and it was hard you know I
mean it's very complicated but that's
how it comes out so then I write that
out and uh I usually I know the ending I
know the title I start writing the first
page
I still don't know exactly how the story
is going to go but it just comes
together and it comes out in six pages
okay
now where it's about four o'clock in the
afternoon
so I make something to eat and I then
that night I watched something on TV
maybe a movie or something
during the movie I get all kinds of
ideas for tweaking the story a little
bit here a little bit there what if I
change this word to that word
then I sleep on it
the next morning I start re I rewrite
the whole thing
and then I let it set and I sleep on it
one more night in case I get any more
little subtleties or innuendos or
whatever
and then it's done and I send it off but
it always starts out with the title I
never have trouble
going through the whole process and
finishing it but I have other friends
who can't do that they they halfway
through or when they get towards the end
they ended and they don't finish it
because it puts finality on something
and a lot of people are afraid to finish
it because
somebody then
besides themself selves is going to have
to read it
and judge it and decide whether to buy
it or not to buy it and they can't take
that because they take a rejection
is a personal attack or rejection of
themselves their own self-worth as a
person
I've got rejections
rolled off my back because when I first
started I got some rejection deservedly
earned the rejection slips you wouldn't
believe I got one that just said
we would admire your persistence Mr Blue
Book but come now
and you know and it was it almost
destroyed me at the time but I got so
many of those it just kind of rolled off
the back and I learned
being in a position where I hire people
myself
reasons why people get rejected that
have nothing to do with the quality of
the work or their worth of the human
being one is what I said before if it
comes in and you have your meeting on a
Monday or Friday that but
what if you have a meeting you walk in
the office
you're going to be hired as
a writer let's say by a story editor or
a publisher or whatever
and you just happen to look like
the girlfriend he had a bad argument
with that morning or that night before
and that's all he sees
and he doesn't hire you or
you're a movie uh casting director
and you've already hired
a six foot tall leading lady with red
hair
and then a guy comes in to auditions for
a leading man role and he's five feet
seven
with flaming red hair you're not going
to put those two people together it's
it'd be ridiculous or in my case when I
was casting my first movie an actress
came in who looked like she could be the
twin sister of somebody we already hired
and you know that confuses people and um
a lot of creative people have to learn
that that's those are reasons why
they're turned down in many cases